-Welcome back to "Late Night".
We're here with Gwen Stefani.
Often times, on "The Voice",
people will do covers,
sometimes even covers
of your music.
-That's true.
-Do your ears like hearing it?
-You know, I get really excited,
but John Legend is known
to not press his button if
someone does one of his songs.
And we're just kind of like,
"John, just -- you have
to press your button.
They're doing your song."
And I guess he gets, like, very
scientific about it,
and he just gets overwhelmed.
But people have done mine,
not -- I can't say when,
'cause this hasn't come out yet.
But I know one season,
somebody did "Cool",
and I wasn't on that season,
and Blake was like,
"Oh, my God,
they did your song!"
And it was just a totally weird
version of it,
and it's awesome.
I love -- they're always doing
covers on that show.
-It's really great.
-Yeah.
-I was just wondering -- it's so
funny because, obviously,
you have these intense
relationships with your songs.
I'm wondering when you hear
somebody else do it,
is it, "Oh, that's so nice that
I'm sharing,"
or is it, "Get your hands
off it"?
-[ Chuckles ] No, I love to hear
them do it,
it's just that sometimes
I feel like
because they're so personal,
the lyrics,
and then if they're like
[Vocalizing] like, doing
all these, like, fancy, like,
vocals on it,
I'll be like, "Oh, that's so..."
-It wasn't actually what I was
feeling the day I wrote that
or ever.
-Or, like, they're a way better
singer, so they're, like, making
it, like, different.
So, yeah, it's always flatt--
-You're being very diplomatic,
and I appreciate that.
-But it's very flattering.
-That's nice.
-And it's incredible.
-I want to talk about
your makeup line...
-Yes, please.
-...GXVE.
And this is really cool, and
you're doing something
even cooler -- this is what the
box will look like.
-I was gonna say, "Is there
something in there?"
[ Laughter ]
-I don't think so.
-I feel like we've got
some, like, lip glosses for you.
-Thank you so much.
But talk about GXVE Community,
'cause this is a really
nice partnership thing
you're doing.
Well, I mean, back in the day, I
did a lot of different things,
but I wanted to, when my life
kind of fell apart --
I don't know people know, but I
had a really, like, bad chapter.
And I just was trying to figure
out what I'm gonna do
for the rest of my life,
you know?
Even my parents were like,
"Don't do anything."
And I was like, "But I kind of
want to do something creative
still," so I've always been
into makeup.
I was a makeup artist way back
in the day.
I worked at the counter, and
I did makeovers on people.
And I just love the way makeup
makes people feel
and how powerful it can be
and just confidence
and all the things
that it brings.
And also just an art, like,
expressing yourself.
So I felt like people -- there
was a really big community
out there already of people that
are just, like, makeup fanatics
like I am.
So I started the line, but I
wanted it to be more
not just about the makeup,
but also about the community
and giving people a chance
to be part of something
that I've done.
And, like, literally, they can
make, like, sell the makeup
and make money off
of the collection that they get.
So it's, like, it's just one
of these things where
just take it another
step further.
Like, you could either work
at the counter,
but you can do it from home,
and you can, like, build up
your followers, you can have
your own platform,
you can share the makeup.
It's like they're already doing
it, but it's kind of
making a place for them to all
come together.
-That's really nice, and you,
I would imagine
back in the early days,
obviously, it's all changed now,
but you are doing the kind of
maybe grittier music venues
with those smaller green rooms.
And you were doing
your own makeup.
-I've done my own makeup
my whole life,
and, you know, only until
recently I got to work
with amazing people
and learn so much,
and I'm still learning.
And that's what's so fun
about the community,
everybody sharing.
Like, we, back in the day,
we didn't have that,
but now, we have access
to all this information
and tutorials and great makeup.
And so -- but back in the day,
I was in a compact on a bus
with, like, all guys around me,
and the bus is moving.
-[ Laughs ]
-And I -- you know,
it was very challenging.
But I'm actually nervous talking
about this,
'cause it's such a big dream
of mine.
I've been working on this
for over four years.
Announcing it, like -- it's one
thing to come out
with a makeup line, to come out
with this community
where people can actually
partner with me
and be like, "You guys, you've
been, exchanging love
all this time, and now you're
gonna get paid for it."
Like, it's kind of exciting
for me to, like, be talking
to you about it.
I'm like, "Aah!" [ Chuckles ]
-Well, it's really --
-I hope I'm explaining
it right. [ Laughs ]
-I think you're doing
a great job.
And I think that's really
exciting, and I think people
probably can't wait to
get involved with it.
And it is just always such
a pleasure to have you here,
and in person,
better than any other way.
Thank you so much --
-You're better in person, too.
-Okay, thank you.
You guys, Gwen Stefani!
"The Voice" premiers
September 19th at 8 P.M.
on NBC.
And GXVE Beauty is available
at Sephora and gxvebeauty.com.
We'll be right back
with Grant Morrison.